more brutal russian shelling in ukraine
as both sides try to reach a ceasefire
during a new round of talks ukraine says
there's possible room for compromise
despite the bombardment of kiev and a
shocking report from marriott poll
russian forces bombing a theater where
civilians were sheltering trey yangste
is in keeve with the latest trey
judge good afternoon an extremely
disturbing report out of the southern
ukrainian city of mariopol where
officials say russian forces bombed a
theater that this week had hundreds of
people hiding in from russian strikes
you can see in these satellite images
before the bombing in the front and back
of this theater
people had written the word children in
russian to let those forces know this
was a place for civilians not a place
for military you can see the destruction
in the aftermath of this strike today
rescue workers are still looking for
anyone who might have been inside at the
time of the strike but just another
example of russian forces targeting
civilian areas here in the capital of
kiev russia continues to advance they
are now targeting buildings inside the
city this morning two people were
injured after a 12-story residential
building was hit with a russian shell
rescue workers evacuated 37 others
according to a statement released by
emergency services ukrainian air defense
does remain active over the city as
russia also tries to attack from the air
ukrainian officials say their military
has launched a number of
counter-offensives across this country
this drone video captures a ukrainian
strike against a russian tank in the
eastern part of the country and in that
southern city of mariopol thousands of
people have been able to escape
via car through humanitarian corridors
though the deputy prime minister of
ukraine says the agreements around these
evacuation routes are being violated by
the russians and that some people are
even being held hostage she had this to
say about the situation
occupants were shooting at humanity
convoys of buses residential areas and
points of gathering of people as well as
taking as hostages the accompanying
people
so our rescuer oliesky danchenko has
been still kept hostage
a short while ago we heard air raid
sirens in the capital city we've heard
small arms fire in the distance all of
this as kiev remains under a 35-hour
curfew back to you
thanks trey
you know um
sandra it seems that
you know when we watch the build-up
we watch the 40-mile uh convoy you know
do very little but now it seems that
they've gotten the word be as brutal as
possible i mean in the last few days
it's almost like you know just hit the
civilians hit the children hit the
refugee corridors the hospitals i mean
it's become more and more brutal is he
desperate putin absolutely um
you know you watch that and you watch
the attacks on the civilians that we had
today and you go back to the question
about air power i was just looking at a
tweet while we were at commercial break
from nikki haley who was saying that we
need to allow the fighter jet transfers
but we also need to levy catastrophic
sanctions on russia's energy sector to
greg's point their economy has been
decimated but
when they continue to carry out attacks
like that there is still military might
and and and money behind that fight and
i think it's an interesting thing to
bring up going back to zalinski's points
this morning in addition to everything
he's asking for he's still asking us to
cut off all american companies from
doing business in russia no russian
goods and american ports i mean there
are still ways we could be cutting off
vladimir putin in this moment and
there's some crazy stories out there
about china obviously china sees
their oil on sale right now there's talk
about saudi arabia willing to cut off
the use of the us dollar for
transferring uh oil sales to china and
using the yuan for that basing on that
devaluing the us dollar so there still
could be catastrophic consequences for
vladimir putin when it comes to the
economy and decimating him from the
ability to continue to ramp up the fight
to the level that you just suggested you
know jesse what's interesting is that
there were so many companies that
decided on their own they almost
self-regulated and they said we're not
going to do business with russia and
then we need zielinski who's in the
middle of a war i mean he's probably the
most stressed guy in the world or one of
them and he's got to remind biden to say
you know maybe you want to do what what
sandra is talking about doing it's
really pathetic how we're not doing
everything we can to stop putin there's
more we can do and we're keeping that in
our back pocket and you want to be
united with well i think you want to
ramp it up if he goes and kills
zielinski or if he does something worse
you gotta you know always keep a few
bullets in the chamber and i don't think
germany's ready to go all in yet but
they might eventually get there here's
how putin survives this here's how
russia survives this he has to cut a
deal with zielinski if he kills zelinski
he is
worse than he is i mean he is the
russian bin laden at that point
sanctions go from a six to a ten you
load that country up with weapons and
it's over you'll have the economy of
mongolia you're looking at so what he's
going to do now is he will encircle the
capital as fast as possible and that
changes the dynamic and then that's when
the real negotiations start zielinski
has to decide am i going to negotiate or
die if he dies well then that's it for
vladimir putin if he negotiates putin
will say i'll take this in the south
i'll take this in the east and we'll
negotiate neutrality and then i'll back
up and i'll try to take the sanctions
away that's his only game that is his
only end game at this point but you know
what this is now
the the best armed insurgency in the
history of mankind these guys are armed
to the teeth you think about the
american revolutionary war the vietnam
war you know how long insurgencies can
last almost 20 years was our last one so
we didn't have sanctions hitting us
every day the russians have sanctions so
they're up against the clock and that's
why they have to move so fast to circle
the capital you know one of the things
that zielinski uh says that that
russia's now in these in these apparent
negotiations behind you know their
background that russia is talking more
realistically and they're saying that um
there's cautious optimism and that keeve
should renounce ambitious the ambitions
to join nato which zelinski has already
said he would do
and promise not to host foreign military
bases or weaponry in exchange for
protection from allies here's my problem
with negotiations in this particular
case i'm all for negotiations generally
speaking here however
you have
a baby killer i hate to use i mean
sometimes i i tend to be hyperbolic but
this is not you but
but this is true this is this man has
targeted women and children
how does it end but my point is going
back to what
book jesse and greg have said
this is mother russia
is
is now has cancer
and the cancer is going to kill mother
russia unless mother russia exercises
this demon there's no way i believe that
this man
can negotiate anything
there's no way that russia can have him
as its face
going forward and try to integrate
itself back in the world economy
how do you fly back to moscow now how do
you fly back to moscow knowing that they
unleashed hell
on on the most vulnerable population on
earth that they committed atrocities
look what they're doing they are in the
business of
destroying utterly
a civilized
industrialized nation they have they
have taken a 21st century country there
and they're trying to send it back to
the stone age how do you negotiate with
this person well
how does it end is the better question
it ends i tell you
here
here's that let me do very very brief
very very briefly russia
gets exhausted because of the heroism of
the ukrainians and those russian
soldiers start going home they start in
the same way they did in 1917 when they
said
screw you we're going home
all right what's going on greg how does
it end well you know that's i god i hate
to say that geraldo had a good point but
the fact is
zielinski did something very smart in
which he actually talks to the russian
soldiers and he talks to the russian
soldiers about the future
assuming that you will be alive then
right and he says you know you got to
think about what what's what it's going
to be like after this how are you how
are you going to go home how are you
going to face your family and that kind
that was a pretty important thing it
wasn't today it was some other time and
um i do think
you know putin could end up being the
face of russia if russia decides to
become north korea that's the only way
he can survive is of what did they used
to call it a hamlet country if i mean
he's russia is going to be so cut off i
was talking to my wife today about you
know because i have relatives in ukraine
and in
in moscow and it's like they are
disgusted and repulsed they can't talk
about it because they're terrified of
the cops take their phones and look at
their phones it's like it's pretty much
over for putin as a as a world leader he
may like he could take an off-ramp as
they call it but after that when he goes
back somebody's going to take care of
him because they can't because
to your point they can't they can't go
forward with him
as their face it's like it's he has he
has crap the bed and there's no use
having them around anymore i think that
i think russia's going to take care of
it i think it depends on on the power
that he has in the military but but if
the economy is shot which it will be
then the question hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else